so what exactly goes into a bios one
well so the bios one is a double layout
with a half twist at the end
um i remember watching simone biles do
it on tv
and i remember thinking
that it would be so cool to do the same
skill as the greatest gymnast of all
time
so it took a lot of hard work it took
overcoming a lot of mental blocks
overcoming
injuries
and i always had to remember that god
has great plans for me and to know and
trust and believe in that it also took
support from my family my coaches and
especially my teammates to get me
through those hard days
and i just knew
that i really wanted to
leave
j.o and go to college
doing something big and going with no
regrets
uh well you know what actually for me
the coolest part because i
played team sports and i loved sports
because of that like playing them and it
was cool because your teammates were
like they were oh as if they landed it
they were that excited like they it was
if they did the trick and i think that
that's so cool to have that kind of
support and and to learn that kind of um
i don't know just
to be able to work with people like that
that teamwork is really invaluable those
lessons um but simone actually retweeted
that video so what did you think of that
well at first i didn't believe it it was
kind of crazy because she's simone biles
so
um
it was just really i was in shock and
didn't believe it at first it just
didn't feel real
thank you so much for working so hard to
do something that's so inspiring to
others all right thank you
[Music]